SCP-507 – otherwise known as the Reluctant
Dimension Hopper – is an anomaly with a
rare condition.
Don’t worry though, it’s not contagious…
we think.
No, this otherwise seemingly ordinary fellow
possesses a rather unpredictable anomalous
trait: he can travel to other dimensions.
That sounds great, in theory, right?
Who among us wouldn’t want to visit alternate
universes and see worlds beyond our wildest
imaginations?
Well, the problem is that SCP-507 can’t
actually control this ability, it’s not
something he can do on a whim or by thinking
about it.
Instead, he is relocated to other universes
seemingly at random, which can prove pretty
intrusive during an average Day in the Life
of SCP-507.
6:00 AM
It was still early, far too early for SCP-507
to be awake.
But even while he slept, the Foundation was
making sure they had the necessary measures
in place to keep him comfortably contained.
Or at least, until he next disappeared.
“Your assignment, Officer Dalton,” the
security chief said boredly, sliding a file
across the desk.
“You want me to be the handler for this…
‘Reluctant Dimension Hopper’?”
Dalton replied after she had skimmed through
the file in front of her.
“Special Containment Procedures for SCP-507
clearly dictate that an agent must be present
with the anomaly whenever he leaves his private
quarters,” the chief answered with a sigh,
having barely sipped his morning coffee.
“Just keep an eye on him, do what he asks
as long as his requests don’t violate internal
security.”
“Sir, with respect,” Dalton cleared her
throat.
“This feels like a waste of my talents.
I’m as combat proficient and well-trained
as all other security operatives.
Why do you want me playing day-care for someone
who’s own files refer to him as ‘sporting
no outstanding characteristics’?
“What, you thought we’d hire you and immediately
put you in the pen with 682?”
the security chief scoffed.
“Don’t look a gift horse in the mouth,
Officer.
This posting is a blessing, believe me.
I’ve given agents just as competent as you
tougher posts and the number of them who died
on the job…
well, let’s just say it makes it easier
being up this early in the day.”
“But, sir, I could be doing more!”
“Trust me, start small.
You’ll have your hands full with SCP-507,
he might not seem like much, but he’s slippery,”
the chief said.
“You mean, he’ll attempt to escape?”
Dalton asked.
The facility’s head of security didn’t
give an answer, instead he dismissed the officer
to her posting.
Making her way through the corridors towards
SCP-507’s containment cell, Officer Dalton
studied her briefing, reading it through multiple
times so she understood her assignment.
She was expecting her charge to be unruly,
attempting escape at any opportunity.
What she had overlooked, in her haste, was
that SCP-507 wasn’t intentionally using
his dimension hopping powers to escape.
In fact, he couldn’t help it.
8:00 AM
Eventually growing tired of waiting outside
the entrance to the Reluctant Dimension Hopper’s
quarters, Officer Dalton began repeatedly
banging her fist against the door.
“SCP-507, wake yourself up!” she yelled
impatiently.
There came the sound of tired groaning from
the other side of the door, followed by something
person sized falling over in a daze.
Getting to its feet, the source of the noise
shuffled closer and opened the door, all while
Dalton kept knocking.
“That’s very loud, you know,” SCP-507
groaned, eyes half-lidded, practically still
asleep.
“I’m your new handler,” the Officer
announced plainly.
“Goody for you,” the Dimension Hopper
yawned.
“I’m tired and going back to sleep.”
“Like hell you are!”
Dalton snapped, striding into the room.
“I’ve been waiting outside for two hours!”
“Look, miss,” SCP-507 sighed.
“I get the Foundation has to keep an eye
on me in case I…”
He made a gesture with his hands, jazzily
shaking them.
“You get the picture,” he continued.
“But I’m normally in bed for the first
half of the day.”
“First of all,” Dalton replied sternly.
“I’m an officer in the Foundation.
As such, you’ll refer to me as ‘Officer
Dalton’ or ‘Ma’am’, is that clear?”
She didn’t give 507 a chance to answer.
“Secondly, make no mistake: I’m not your
babysitter.
I’m here to ensure the Foundation’s continued
security, not yours.
And if one of your escape attempts poses a
threat to this organisation, then I am authorised
to carry out a termination order.
In short, don’t screw around with me.”
SCP-507 looked sheepish, like a schoolchild
who’d just been told off by the principal.
“So, am I right in thinking you like to
go by nicknames?
What do I call you?”
He paused for a second, a cheeky smirk crawling
onto his face as he figured out a way he could
slyly mess with the no-nonsense officer.
“You can call me Grabnok the Destroyer,”
SCP-507 replied.
Officer Dalton rolled her eyes: this was clearly
going to be a long day.
10:00 AM
Sure enough, the newly appointed handler’s
first cause for concern came when SCP-507
suddenly blinked out of existence while brushing
his teeth.
She’d urged him to get himself ready and
freshened up, and no sooner had ‘Grabnok’
stepped into the bathroom, he’d disappeared,
his toothbrush clattering into the sink.
Officer Dalton stared in disbelief at the
spot where he had just been, bowled over by
how brazen and how quickly the anomalous interdimensional
traveller had tried to give her the slip.
Immediately, Dalton went to raise the alarm,
only to be ineffectively reassured by her
superiors.
‘This kind of thing happens all the time’
and ‘He’ll reappear soon, just keep sweeping
the facility until he shows up’ were all
she was met with.
And they did little to quell Dalton’s frustration.
Eventually, SCP-507 reappeared, wandering
around one of the corridors of the Foundation
facility and whining about a headache that
usually accompanied his dimensional displacement.
“What the hell are you playing at vanishing
like that?”
Dalton barked.
“I need to eat something,” Grabnok groaned,
ignoring her question.
“I displaced before breakfast; it always
makes me nauseous when it’s on an empty
stomach.”
“That’s your primary concern right now?”
the Officer sighed.
“Well, yeah,” SCP-507 shrugged.
“There was no food in that other dimension,
at least none that I could find.”
Begrudgingly pushing aside her frustration,
Dalton escorted Grabnok to the Foundation
mess hall.
“What else was there, SCP-507?”
she asked, breaking the silence as he ate
quietly.
“I’ll have to file a report about where
you went.”
“Not answering to that,” he chuckled.
“You’ve got to use the nickname.”
“Seriously?”
Dalton replied.
“Okay, fine, what else was in that universe,
Grabnok?”
“The whole thing.”
“Grabnok the Destroyer,” she added through
gritted teeth.
“Not a lot honestly,” the Dimension Hopper
shrugged.
“Some universes are just like that, this
one just had one big salt plane and nothing
else.”
“You mean like a desert?”
Dalton probed.
“No, a salt plane,” Grabnok corrected
her.
“You know, like a glass salt shaker you’d
have at a fancy dinner table?
Except with wings.”
“And what was in the… salt plane?”
she asked, confused.
“I think it was white pepper,” SCP-507
answered sarcastically.
12:00 PM
After he had finished his meal, SCP-507 seemed
to be feeling better, and requested to be
taken back to his quarters to use his computer.
He’d been granted one by the Foundation,
with limited internet access and a strict
limit on what he could access and upload.
However, it was while escorting him back that
Officer Dalton realized her charge had once
again relocated while her back was turned.
Dalton once again proceeded to traverse the
facility’s corridors, checking in with other
security staff and telling her fellow personnel
to keep her posted if SCP-507.
Meanwhile, unbeknownst to her, the Reluctant
Dimension Hopper had found himself in a particularly
unique situation.
Arriving in a new alternate universe, SCP-507
was greeted by familiar headaches, standing
in a spot that mirrored the Foundation site
he had been in a moment before.
In fact, most of the details about this universe
were almost identical to the one he had just
left…
apart from all the dinosaurs.
It quickly became apparent, at the sight of
a velociraptor wearing a lab coat, that this
was a reality where the meteor that wiped
out early life on Earth had never actually
hit.
As a result, the reptiles that had inhabited
the world centuries before had been able to
evolve into the dominant species, while humanity’s
earliest ancestors had never climbed out of
the primordial soup.
SCP-507 found himself in a facility overrun
with reptilian researchers, all working for
an organization called the ‘Scaly Carnivorous
Predator Foundation’.
Naturally, the dinosaurs were fascinated by
the sudden and inexplicable existence of this
pink, fleshy creature appearing out of thin
air.
Although, the researchers working at this
version of the Foundation were similarly well-versed
in the study of the anomalous.
Unfortunately, there was something of a language
barrier between SCP-507 and the dinosaurs
of this dimension.
A kind, calm request for him to come quietly
so the research reptiles could run tests ended
up sounding like a vicious, bloodthirsty snarl.
And so, the Reluctant Dimension Hopper turned
heel and ran away from a flock of raptors
in Foundation lab coats, until he eventually
displaced back to his original dimension again.
1:30 PM
“Right, sure they did, 507,” Dalton sighed
after her charge had reappeared and recounted
his story of sentient dinosaurs running an
alternate version of the Foundation.
“And I bet Jeff Goldblum and Laura Dern
were both public enemies in this universe
too.”
“I wasn’t in Jurassic Park,” SCP-507
argued, his head splitting.
“I could have been eaten alive if those
raptors caught up to me!”
Officer Dalton helped the blonde haired and
green eyed dimensional traveler to his feet,
and began marching him towards a debriefing
room.
As part of their continued research into not
only SCP-507 but the wider multiverse, the
Reluctant Dimension Hopper often had to describe
his unplanned expeditions after the fact.
“Screw that, I almost died!” he protested.
“I don’t want to go and give a debrief,
I’ll do it later.
It’s got to be past lunch time in this universe,
right?” he asked.
“You eat after debrief,” Dalton insisted.
“Nah, I want lunch,” SCP-507 retorted.
“I need to recharge.
I’ll go and sit with Fernand!”
Reluctantly, remembering she’d been told
to do whatever the Dimension Hopper asked,
Officer Dalton changed course and walked him
towards the enlarged containment area housing
SCP-082.
‘Fernand’ was genetically an ordinary
human being who had grown into a giant through
some unknown means.
Given that SCP-507 was usually permitted to
freely interact with must other relatively
harmless anomalies, he had developed something
of a friendship with SCP-082.
As a result, Grabnok considered his visits
to be a vacation of sorts.
Despite Fernand’s grotesque appearance,
the giant was actually very friendly, especially
towards SCP-507.
The creature’s body was dense with muscle
and fat, heavily scarred and his face disproportioned
to the rest of him.
Yet, both SCP-082 and SCP-507 seemed to converse
jovially and enjoyed each other’s company
over lunch.
That is, until the Reluctant Dimension Hopper
unceremoniously displaced again, midway through
talking to his giant friend about his latest
multiversal excursion.
SCP-082 turned to Officer Dalton the second
Grabnok had vanished and shrugged casually.
“He does that.”
4:00 PM
Over the course of the next few hours, at
least as the time passed in his home dimension,
SCP-507 was relocated into a universe where
everyone on Earth was a sentient hot dog.
It was a jarring change to adapt to, although
not quite as initially frighting as encountering
the dinosaurs on his previous outing.
The hot dog population were a bit more guarded
that the inhabitants of the last universe
he’d been to, but after ensuring them that
he meant no harm, SCP-507 quickly established
a rapport with some of them.
The first question he had was whether, like
the dinosaurs, these anthropomorphic baseball
stand snacks had naturally evolved into the
dominant species over time.
SCP-507 was surprised to learn that, in actuality,
these hot dog creatures had previously been
human, until a strange plague had befallen
them several hundred thousand years prior.
Ironically, this had all taken place before
their civilisation had even developed the
practice of eating sausages in bread.
“Okay, so let me follow that up with another
question,” SCP-507 declared.
“Make it quick man, I’m late for work,”
the large talking hot dog replied.
“So, when you all changed into hot dogs,
did you really become sausages then develop
bread coats to wear?
Or are you both?”
“Wait, what do you mean?”
the hot dog person replied.
“You know, because technically a hot dog
isn’t a hot dog unless you put it in a bread
roll,” SCP-507 explained.
“So are you all actually sausages, or are
you like coalescent beings of both sausage
and bread?
The ensuing political unrest, civil turmoil
and ethical outcry that overtook the hot dog
dimension following SCP-507’s question made
him really glad he displaced back home not
long after.
He couldn’t help feel a little disheartened
too; up until the hot dogs were trying to
place him over a giant grill, SCP-507 had
actually found that he’d been enjoying the
time he spent there.
Still, he was grateful to be back in a universe
populated by actual humans once again, even
if the first one he met upon returning – Officer
Dalton – was furious that he’d been gone
for so long.
7:00 PM
“You know, I’m wise to your act,” she
replied.
SCP-507 had just requested dinner, although
for some reason pointed out that he wanted
to avoid eating hot dogs for a while.
“What act?” he asked.
“This thing you do, your disappearing act,”
the Officer responded.
“You’re not this bumbling interdimensional
traveller, you’re just an immature brat,
SCP-507.”
“You have to call me-”
“Grabnok the whoever!
Or Tommy, or Guy, or whatever the hell your
name is at this precise moment in time!”
Dalton snapped angrily, forcing SCP-507 to
go silent.
“You just teleport, that’s what you do.
You zip out of one place and reappear in the
next, and give personnel like me a run around.
And it’s a hoot, it’s just a big joke
you can pull on us.
That would be bad enough, if you didn’t
come back with these absurd stories on top
of it.
What’s next, huh?
A dimension where the Foundation is run by
cats?
Or a world where everyone is a sentient fart?”
“I don’t make it up,” SCP-507 replied
meekly.
“The place I end up in are real, I don’t
get to pick where I displace to or how weird
it is when I get there.”
“No, I said that I’ve figured you out,”
Dalton retorted.
“You make up some wild story, these fool
yarns you keep spinning to confuse people.
Then, you can request anything you want.
That’s your real anomalous trait, Grabnok
the Destroyer, you’re able to pull the wool
over our eyes and use it to garner special
privileges.
A computer, almost total freedom to roam around
the Foundation at will.
Food and board, anything you want you get.”
There was a long, awkward pause.
SCP-507 looked miserable.
He was aware that, as cruel as she was being,
Officer Dalton’s anger was born more out
of frustration than anything else.
He couldn’t help his interdimensional displacement
disorder.
Sure, it had meant the Foundation offered
him certain treatment someone might consider
to be preferential.
But he was still trapped, not so much by the
facility or even the Foundation themselves.
Instead, SCP-507 was trapped by his condition,
unable to freely choose which universe he
stayed in.
8:00 PM
Dalton had escorted SCP-507 to debrief, then
back to his quarters.
The entire time, an air of uncomfortable silence
followed them.
She still wasn’t entirely convinced that
her charge’s anomalous ability wasn’t
all a sham – at least in part.
But standing guard at his bedroom door, she
could see him sulkily browsing the internet
on his computer.
He was quiet, and Dalton couldn’t help that
it did make her feel a little bad for losing
her temper at him earlier.
“Hey, SCP-507,” she said, poking her head
through the doorway.
He didn’t respond, mindlessly scrolling
without turning around.
Stepping inside, Dalton closed the gap between
them by walking towards SCP-507, sat in his
computer chair.
“Listen, SCP-507,” she repeated, then
realising why he wasn’t replying or paying
her any notice.
With a roll of her eyes and a heavy, exasperated
sigh, Officer Dalton readdressed the Reluctant
Dimension Hopper: “Hey, Grabnok the Destroyer.”
Hearing that made SCP-507 turn around in an
instant, giving her his full attention.
“Ma’am,” he said, still sulking but
at least willing to speak.
“I’m very sorry for what I said before,”
Dalton admitted.
“I don’t enjoy this, you know,” SCP-507
said solemnly.
“One minute I’m somewhere familiar, the
next I’m thrust into some horrible nightmare
where everyone’s got macaroni cheese for
hands, or there are so many spiders everywhere.
It’s not a joke to me, and it sucks!”
There were tears in the Dimension Hopper’s
eyes, and Officer Dalton reached out to pat
him on the shoulder.
“I know, and I’m sorry for saying you
made it all up,” she offered a smile.
Then, in the blink of an eye, they were both
gone.
10:00 PM
Every other time that SCP-507 had displaced
during the day, the Foundation had barely
paid it any mind, not even reacting when Officer
Dalton had brought it to their attention.
But the moment she had disappeared along with
the Reluctant Dimension Hopper, security staff
and researchers went into a frenzy.
Alarms were sounded, personnel were patrolling
the corridors en masse, sweeping room to room
with flashlights in the hope not only that
SCP-507 would return… but that Officer Dalton
would still be with him when he did.
It had been a few hours since the pair of
them had vanished, the sun had long since
sent and night had fallen.
Yet, there was still no sign… until a researcher
heard the sound of someone sobbing coming
from one of the storage closets.
Calling it in, a trio of Foundation security
cautiously approached the closet and threw
open the door, only to find SCP-507 sat inside,
weeping floods of tears.
Immediately, despite how late at night it
was, the Reluctant Dimension Hopper was told
he needed to debrief on where he had just
been, and what had happened to his handler,
Officer Dalton.
SCP-507 began to describe displacing to a
dimension he had visited a number of times
before, a reality that was shrouded in complete
darkness, no sunlight at all.
A familiar sound had instantly told the Reluctant
Dimension Hopper where he was and that he
wasn’t alone.
Doubly so, because Officer Dalton’s hand
had been on his shoulder.
Completely by accident, she had transported
there with him.
Switching on the flashlight he took with him
everywhere, SCP-507 was horrified to see a
figure who had tormented him before.
He wore a black business suit, the matching
sunglasses he had on made the figure resemble
a ‘man in black’ agent.
It leered at him and Officer Dalton with an
unnaturally wide smile that had haunted SCP-507’s
nightmares ever since their first encounter.
“Back again,” the figure had said, leaning
in towards SCP-507.
“And this time you’ve brought a friend…”
“He took her,” the Reluctant Dimension
Hopper said quietly as he sat in the debriefing
room.
“The Smiling Man got her.”
“We better get you cleaned up and sent to
bed, SCP-507,” one of the researchers said,
forcing a reassuring smile.
“We’ll assign you another new handler
in the morning.”
Now go and check out “SCP-507 RELUCTANT
DIMENSION HOPPER” and “CAN SCP-096 CHASE
ITS VICTIMS ACROSS THE MULTIVERSE?”
for more background on the man who can traverse
the multiverse… and quite literally can’t
stop.